[Music]
well you go to your brain you go to your
head I mean to find out what's what
you're thinking about what you're
feeling what what does going on in your
life and hopefully you can find those
experiences that you're having and have
them reflected in the screenplays and in
the movies that you make so usually you
go to go to your own head look inside
your head see what's in there hopefully
there's something interesting well I've
been asked this question a lot and my
favorite film of all time is It's a
Wonderful Life Frank Capra and I've seen
the movie 40 times and interestingly
enough as I've gotten older the movie
gets better and better now obviously the
movie hasn't changed but as you get
older we realize how precious life is
and the movie takes on a greater meaning
as I get older so it's a wonderful life
[Music]
well you know I can't answer that
question because that's for other people
too to answer I mean I like a lot of the
films I've done you know I mean you
they're like your children we love them
all equally but you know I mean I have a
partial place in my heart for Princess
for Princess Bride I also have a place
in my heart for When Harry Met Sally
because I met my wife when I made that
film also as I would say stand by me is
probably the most important film to me
you know I've been very fortunate and
that I've made two films with with Jack
Nicholson and Morgan Freeman and I would
have to say those two Morgan Freeman I
just finished the film with him and if I
could make every film with Morgan
Freeman I would he's the most brilliant
actor and a pleasure absolute president
pleasure to work with you know it's
people always ask me about sequels and I
you know I to me I make a movie because
it has a finite beginning middle and end
and that's the that's the movie and
that's the story I wanted to tell so I
don't really think about sequels too
much I mean spinal tap was probably the
only one that would lend itself to a
sequel would be interesting to see if
these guys could ever still get on a
stage and well they can we look at the
Rolling Stones they're doing it so I
guess you can do it until you drop dead
I would say yes stand by me probably the
most personal for me at the time it it
probably reflects my personality and my
sensibility more so than any of the
others it has a real mixture of
melancholy drama and humor and it was
the first film I made that I really felt
reflected like I say my sensibility and
and the fact that it was successful it
helped me it helped validate the kind of
films that I like to make
[Music]